during covid everybody pretty much
accepted the who had dropped the ball
except that there was a need for reform
there has been no reform whatsoever the
wrote show is doubling down in all sorts
of different ways it's just being given
an extra 20 funding from the member
states and as far as I can see none of
those member states are saying well we'd
like to we'd like to see you clean up
your act I mean maybe we'd like a new
director general for example I mean Dr
tedris's judgment is absolutely
appalling you might remember he tried to
appoint Mugabe as Goodwill Ambassador
early on I mean that's just it's
literally incredible it's unbelievable
that anybody would think that that's a
good move a good look and yet he did it
and in a way that illustrates how broken
this organization is because any other
organization on Earth you would think
including probably even FIFA would say
we're not going to appoint Mugabe is a
Goodwill in battle last night even if we
secretly like him for whatever reason
we're not going to do it but he took an
international backlash for them to
rescind that appointment